[Music]
I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street
Journal this is a special episode of
tech news briefing part of our four-part
series on climate Tech today we're
talking about the power of
transformation
carbon transformation that is you may
have heard of carbon sequestration where
carbon is captured from the air or in
factories turned into a solid or a
liquid and then stuck deep underground
but what if instead of burying all that
carbon it was turned into something
useful
Green Tech investing has rebounded from
a bust about a decade ago particularly
over the last two years carbon and
Emissions tech companies raised more
than ten and a half billion dollars from
Venture investors in the first three
quarters of 2022 according to pitchbook
of that more than three and a half
billion went specifically towards carbon
management companies focused on
capturing sequestering and transforming
carbon our climate Finance reporter
amrith Ram Kumar says many investors see
carbon transformation as something of a
Holy Grail it's this sort of Trash to
Treasure process that eliminates
emissions and then it turns into a
useful product so people find that idea
easy to understand and they're super
excited about it because of the
environmental impact the challenge is of
course how to do this profitably and in
a cost-competitive way and that's the
piece that no one's really figured out
yet so investors are very excited about
it they're hopeful they're putting money
into companies they think can get there
with government subsidies and other help
but it's still a long path to actually
do it we'll hear more from amworth later
in the show but first one of those
carbon Transformations startups is
Silicon Valley based Ruby it hopes to
change the fashion industry with
textiles made from captured CO2 last
year it raised four and a half million
dollars from investors it also got a
quarter million dollar Grant from the
National Science Foundation
f is Ruby's co-founder and CEO hi Nika
thanks for being here thanks for having
me I want to jump right into what ruby
does the goal is to take carbon out of
the air and turn it into fabric how do
you do that I really think the best way
to think about this is we mimic what
trees do when you think of a tree it
breeds in CO2 so carbon starting as air
right it breathes that in and turns it
into its solid trunk branches and leaves
how it does that is using enzymes
enzymes are these molecules that help
reactions happen and so that's what our
system is basically mimicking and we're
inspired by these powerful systems in
nature we're able to take CO2 from a gas
form we collect that from manufacturing
facilities so facilities that would have
normally emitted that CO2 in the
atmosphere what is your fabric when it
comes out is this something different
from Fabrics that we're familiar with
now so our material is actually the same
material material that is already used
in textiles it's the third most common
family of textiles it's called man-made
cellulosic fibers as the industry lingo
but what that really looks like if you
check the tag on your clothes is you
might see it as viscose lyocell rayon
Jersey even some Satins
so it's a pretty common material and
that's just our first material Focus so
what we're also developing with some of
these apparel Brands is sort of our next
step of product development in the
apparel space which is mimicking
cotton-like materials and also polyester
materials what stage of development is
Ruby at when it comes to manufacturing
we're at the lab stage right now and
what that looks like is doing materials
testing with cellulose and product that
we produce in our lab we're partnering
with apparel Brands and manufacturers
right now at the pilot stage to
basically do this materials testing
progress into garment prototypes and
then soon also do some capsule
collection launches which is basically
thousands of units per brand how do you
scale up and what are the steps that you
need to take and how quickly can you
make those right the big steps for us
are really scaling our production
process so right now we have basically a
1 leader system in the lab and that's
what's doing the CO2 to cellulose
polymer conversion with our enzymes
that's enough for you know this early
materials testing and prototyping but
our next step is basically scaling up
that system and we generally do about
10x increase volumes each time we scale
up and that's what unlocks the capsule
Collections and then real
commercialization the timelines there
are actually
relatively very fast and what we look at
is trying to be faster than what brands
are used to with materials innovators
by using technologies that have really
great maturity across other Industries
so we're using Technologies from the
food and beverage industry that have
already been scaled but we're able to
apply it to basically a new application
which allows us to know that as we scale
we can do things faster than a
completely new untested technology that
might take you know years and years and
years to commercialize
from the food and
food and processes for decades and when
you look at things like high fructose
corn syrup production or lactose free
milk it actually uses Cascades of
enzymes and so that's something that
we've been able to leverage really
heavily as we scale up our system design
which is certainly more complex but is
able to use some similar principles so
the tools you need to scale up with your
technology are there how fast are we
talking though we're not saying exactly
all of our launch timelines but what
we're really excited about is we're
expecting to be able to with some of our
brand partners and Manufacturing
Partners launch capsule Collections and
that's you know thousands of units per
brand and then into 2024 that's the year
that we expect to achieve really
significant commercialization scale so
let's talk about cost a bit how will
your product then compare to what's
already on the market yeah so at the lab
stage that we're at today making you
know small batches it's definitely a
higher price point but that's just for
our limited time sort of lab testing
what we're intending is by the time we
get to Market which is aiming for end of
2023 early 2024 where consumers can
actually buy this in stores that our
material would be the same price as the
textiles that are used in those garments
and so what that will look like for
consumers is
everything will you know be the same
price points that you're used to and
that's sort of just the beginning we
actually as we continue to grow expect
our costs to dramatically drop and
become cheaper than standard textile
price points over 2024 and Beyond and
that's something that also for us helps
unlock those other verticals Beyond just
textiles so going into building
materials food packaging and more Nika
mashup CEO of Ruby thank you so much for
joining us thank you
Ruby is by no means the only company
making a push into the carbon
transformation market and like Ruby many
of these companies are still in the
early phases of development there are
plenty of questions about whether they
can make the numbers add up and turn a
profit or even live up to their Promises
of making an overall environmental
impact
joining me to discuss that is Wall
Street Journal climate investment
reporter amrith ramkumar hi amruth
thanks for joining me thanks so much for
having me who are the investors who are
focused on this industry the investors
really run the gamut you have Wall
Street firms that are trying and Venture
capitalists who are trying to get in
early with some of the big companies of
the future and this area is one where
people see big breakthroughs coming
hopefully and then you also have a lot
of heavy industry companies so oil and
gas companies they're all looking at the
space and making pretty small
Investments for them and then you also
have chemicals companies that have large
environmental Footprints and the key
there is a lot of these companies are
trying to lower the emissions from their
existing operations and make money by
investing in big companies of the future
and they could also be like potentially
lucrative acquisition targets down the
road we heard about Ruby but amruth
you've spoken with other carbon
transformation companies and can you
tell us about some of them sure one big
one is Lands attack because they've
attracted a lot of money and they're
really focused on basically using like
microbes and biology to turn and carbon
emissions and other emissions at factory
level into useful chemicals that can
basically go right back into the supply
chain so it's kind of this circular
process and then other companies like
Ruby and a host of other really early
stage ones are basically kind of at lab
or really small scale they're trying to
basically create new stuff and use these
biological processes and some more
things that like replicate fibers or
other materials and basically make it
from scratch the challenge there is it's
often a whole new supply chain a whole
new stuff that you need to create and
doing it at a large scale and making it
lower cost is a huge challenge for them
can you tell us a little bit more about
what those challenges are I mean both
for turning this into something and for
turning that something into a business
yeah the main ones are cost and also
still environmental impact because a lot
of these processes need a lot of energy
so people are trying to do it with
low-cost Renewables but but that's
pretty challenging when you're talking
about the large amounts of energy a lot
of these processes need when you're
talking about like lab grown chemicals
or things like that and they can also
consume large amounts of water and other
resources so that's still a barrier and
then just cost is the huge one cost and
scale just how to do this on a large
scale that can be cost competitive with
our existing Supply chains that have
been perfected over decades and huge
companies have earned how to produce
large amounts of materials and chemicals
that come from oil and gas and other
Commodities how are climate activists
viewing this kind of Technology a lot of
people are very wary just because as I
mentioned there are a lot of outstanding
questions about how green it actually is
once you take into account the whole
like life cycle of the process from
beginning to end talking about
potentially having to ship things around
the world and once you do that with
anything in the materials or commodity
space the environmental footprint starts
getting pretty rough so even though a
lot of the companies and people in the
space are doing it with the best of
intentions and doing the best they can
to make the screener product it's a huge
Challenge and I guess that would matter
to on their technical processes for
capturing the carbon and going through
the process of making whatever product
they are because I assume each company
would have a different footprint
exactly when you're that's one of the
attractive things when people talk about
capturing it on site and like reusing it
or turning it into something else is
those carbon emissions already exists
and you're kind of capturing them and
turning them in like the idea of
creating new stuff is where you kind of
lose a lot of environmental analysts and
people because then you're talking about
introducing new sets of resource usage
water usage energy usage and that can be
really tough the scale of an Exon of a
Chevron of the existing oil and gas at
chemicals companies and these Supply
chains and the lab scale or the pilot
scale or the early stage scale these
startups are talking about is just not
even a drop in the bucket I mean those
are some of the challenges that are
specific to carbon transformation but
there are also these economic challenges
that lots of tech companies are facing
at the moment and you mentioned all of
the investor interest I wonder if we
expect to see a pullback given the
economic environment that we're in at
the moment this is where there's like a
silver lining for carbon transformation
and climate Tech broadly is that uh it's
so early stage and risky that it's kind
of seen as a bit insulated from this
economic environment just because no one
really expects any of these companies to
be profitable in the next few years
anyway so some of the ones that have
gone public or trying to go public are
facing some short-term challenges but a
lot of money is still flowing into Clean
Energy Solutions and the investor is
putting money into this don't really
expect it to yield something at scale
tomorrow so it's more of a longer term
bet so again it's seen like the demand
is there and not going away if anything
the demand will only increase as more
companies are under pressure to decar
urbanize there was a boom in climate
Tech about a decade ago that was
followed by a bust I mean how does the
situation now compare to back then clean
energy investors and Executives say it's
night and day compared to about 10 years
ago when you had a climate industry bust
following a big boom around the
financial crisis the big difference
today is just that you have these scaled
Technologies like Renewables and
electric vehicles and batteries that are
growing so quickly and people have seen
that it is happening and it is working
and it's just a matter of time for those
and that's giving a lot of people
confidence that even though there might
be some economic challenges company
challenges investor challenges along the
way that this trend is here to stay and
that so 2022 hasn't been as strong as
2021 which was a record year across the
board but it still held up better than a
lot of people expected and the
government is putting billions of
dollars in as well all right that's our
reporter amrith Ram Kumar thanks for
joining us amrith thanks so much for
having me
all right that's it for this episode of
tech news briefing be sure to check out
the other episodes in our special series
on new climate Tech we had editorial
support on this series from Ed Ballard
Ken Brown Dieter Holger Falana Patterson
Christina Peterson and amrith RAM Kumar
our producer is Julie Chang our
executive producer is Chris sinsley for
more Tech news head over to our website
wsj.com I'm your host Zoe Thomas for The
Wall Street Journal
thanks for listening
foreign
[Music]